- But Taj, you place
fourth on Survivor, so
- Ah
- [Kelly] What's, that's
my sister, she's obsessed.
(Audience applauding)
[Kelly] This is like,
this is my sister's show.
She never missed one thing.
Yeah, so what's surprised you about it?
And why would you do it? This
is my question for everyone.
- Okay, first of all, what
surprised me was that it was real
and I didn't really intend to do it.
I got a call to go on the show
that I had never watched
before or after I went on.
- [Kelly] You didn't really
- I didn't know what I was getting into.
- Oh my God, you thought
it was like a reality.
- I thought it was reality.
- It was a fake reality.
- Yeah, it wasn't. There was
no toilet tissue, nothing.
(audience laughing)
- [Taj] I thought you'd
go out there and get dirty
they'd wash you off and you'd go home
and start again the next day.
The cameras never go off.
- Oh my, well you did well though.
- Look, by the grace of God,
I was out there winning it.
(Audience applauding)
- I love that you totally
didn't think it was
'cause people will be like reality TV
It's kind of real, you know, you probably.
- [Kelly] That's a realization.
- Oh gosh, no, it is real. It is real.
- Wouldn't you ever do it again?
- No.
(laughing)
- So quick. Would anybody
here do that show?
- Yeah,
- [Kelly] Look at her (Kelly laughing)
- Absolutely not.
- I've done a lot of reality
shows but I was scared of that one.